so this was named after the German
physicist German Austrian fizzle is a
Meitner who was one of the people that
just understood the the behavior of
atoms the nuclear fission which is what
causes radiant and radioactive atoms to
fall apart it was she and her nephew
I think Otto Frisch who came up with the
idea of or the analogy of the element of
the nucleus of the element being like a
water droplet and splitting apart into
two halves and the important thing about
nuclear energy is that when the atoms
splits into two halves the weight of the
two halves is slightly less than the
weight of the original nucleus and many
people know that Einstein came up with
equation e equals MC squared where m is
the mass and C is a very large number so
losing even a tiny amount of mass
produces a huge amount of net energy and
this is the origin of the enormous
amount of energy that you can get from
nuclear power nuclear reactions
Lisa Meitner was Jewish and had to flee
from Germany and she went to Sweden
where she worked during the war Sweden
was neutral but and like her
collaborator Otto Hahn she never got
Nobel Prize